Thanks to Skillshare for supporting this
episode of Journey to the Microcosmos.
The first 1,000 people to click on the link in
the description can get a 1 month free trial
of Skillshare’s Premium Membership so you
can start exploring your creativity today.
If you’ve taken a biology class, at some point
you likely had to sit down to a picture of a cell.
It was vaguely oval shaped and filled with
circles and squiggly lines. And your task
was to look at those circles and lines and
assign them labels like “vesicle” or “nucleus.”
And this exercise has its benefits. But at the
same time, the picture it paints of a cell is—by
necessity—static and uniform. The reality is
that cells may be full of analogous parts,
but their lives and physical appearance can appear
vastly different when compared to each other.
The bodies of multicellular organisms like
us are built on that principle, with a
diversity of cells dedicated to different tasks.
But we can see it even more starkly in the lives
of single-celled eukaryotes. These are organisms
who have managed to make an entire way of life
out of a single cell, taking on many
different forms to do so. Even as the
inner parts remain approximately the same,
the final results can be wildly different,
whether you’re looking at the flexible form of
an amoeba or the determined shape of a diatom.
Here on Journey to the Microcosmos,
we often focus on the organisms—on
their fascinating physiology and lives as
they navigate the world around them. But
what about the even smaller world inside of them?
If you think of a cell as its own little world, a
little society built on chemistry and biology, one
of its most important tasks is establishing its
boundaries—separating and protecting the inside of
the cell while still leaving it just open enough
to bring in essential nutrients from the outside.
The essential component here is the plasma
membrane, a double layer of fatty acids that
surrounds the cell and allows some things to pass
while keeping the cell protected.
But for different protists, the cell
membrane may not be quite enough to establish
the kind of boundaries it needs. Ciliates like
these pelagotrix encase their plasma membrane
within a larger structure called the pellicle,
which has structures to define the organism’s
shape and anchor their many hairy cilia.
Other organisms supplement their plasma membrane
with another exterior wall, like this colony of
green algae called Pediastrum. Each of these
cells is encased in a protective cell wall.
What comes next after the boundaries have
been set is, well, everything. It is one
big soup of life, organelles and nutrients
swimming in the watery broth of the cytoplasm.
And just like a good soup, there is a delicate
balance to the cytoplasm. When you’re living in
a watery environment with a thin membrane
separating you from the outside world,
water can seep through. A little bit of that water
might be fine, but too much can be dangerous.
We’ve even seen microbes burst open and die when
they’ve been pushed past their watery limits.
But microbes are not passive in the face of this
danger. If you look at the edge of this Frontonia
vernalis, you can see its solution at work.
There are canals all pointed towards the same
clear, circular region. That area is not just
some blank space. It is a contractile vacuole,
swelling up with water until it is full.
And when it is full, you can see it contract
and push the water out of the cell through
tiny pores, leaving the world within balanced.
And as we travel further inside this world, there
is a flurry of activity, not all of which is
visible to us. Much of that activity is powered
by the mitochondria, though unfortunately they
are a bit too small for us to easily see. But
we think that the thin rods inside this diatom
might be the famous powerhouses of the cell.
The chemicals that mitochondria use to generate
power come from food. And of course, microbes
have found many creative ways to obtain food.
Some organisms make their own, turning light into
sugar through clever chemistry and chloroplasts.
And even though chloroplasts can
come in different shapes and sizes,
they’re usually easy enough to identify through
their most obvious trait: their vibrant green
color, derived from the light-absorbing
chlorophyll that powers the chloroplast.
Except…of course biology loves an exception.
There are examples of other colors in the
chloroplast realm, like in red algae that have
other pigments that stain their chloroplasts red.
Whatever the color, these are organisms
whose inner worlds can sustain themselves,
as long as they get enough light. But other
organisms have to go out and seek their sustenance
by finding other organisms to eat. And if that
sounds like a bit much to you, I will remind you,
you are one of them. So, humans and other
organisms like us have to find a way to
introduce that food into their bodies.
In some organisms, that gate is called
the cytostome. And in this glaucoma,
the cytostome takes the form of an oval,
flapping as the organism turns
around and assesses a possible meal.
But swallowing food is only one step in the
process. After it enters the organism’s body, the
food gets wrapped up in its own little membrane
like a present—a present stuffed with digestive
enzymes that will tear its contents apart.
And just as with water, the cell doesn’t
necessarily want to keep all of this digested food
around for the rest of its life. So what doesn’t
get used gets pooped out through the cytoproct,
and if the mitochondria is the powerhouse of the
cell, the cytoproct is the butthole of the cell.
And then, of course, there are other specialized
parts that help different organisms manage the
specific challenges of their lifestyle. Like
take this Loxodes, which prefers to live in
areas of water that are lower in oxygen—areas
that are, to put it simply, down. Down
the water column, into the depths.
But to get there, the Loxodes needs to figure out
just where “down” is. So the organism relies on
its Muller vesicles, a simple structure, it’s
an organelle that allows it to detect gravity.
The vesicle holds a single mineral granule
attached to a cilium. And as gravity pulls on the
mineral, the mineral pulls on the cilium, pointing
the Loxodes downward like an inner compass.
Now if we take a step back and survey
these little worlds inside of organisms,
it is remarkable to realize that these organisms
have built themselves, assembled and sustained
by their own reactions. They have gathered
and made their resources, and from it comes
all of these different parts that just seem to
work. There are so many bits of chemistry and
probability that have come together to make
each of these tiny remarkable lives happen.
And at the center of so much of that assembly
is the nucleus, those round organelles that hold
the DNA that describes the organism’s existence.
Nuclei are universal among eukaryotes, though of
course ciliates in all of their contrarian glory
have also managed to make their own habits out
of familiar entities. Ciliates are not content to
just have one type of nucleus, no they have two.
The larger nucleus is called the macronucleus, and
it is responsible for the day-to-day genetic needs
of the organism. Whereas the smaller nuclei are
the micronuclei, and their primary role is to pass
on genetic information during sexual reproduction.
It feels right to end with the nucleus,
the part of the cell that ensures not just the
life of this organism itself, but also of its
progeny. It is a map that is passed on and shared,
promising the creation of new worlds to come.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And we would also like to say thank you
to Skillshare for supporting this video.
We’ve discussed Skillshare many times, and we’ve
shared courses that can help you with everything
from learning to paint with watercolors, to
understanding how to properly cook and prepare
fish. But what if you’re not feeling super
confident about starting down a new creative path?
Well, Skillshare is here to
help you with that as well.
In the course “Confidence For Creatives”, host
Eugena Washington will help you develop some
tools to help you reconnect with your self worth
and continue to grow your confidence to do the
creative work that you love. Do you battle with
imposter syndrome? Or are you looking for a burst
of inspiration? Well, if you answered “Yes” to
either of these questions, this class is for you!
Skillshare is an online learning community that
can help you make 2022 a year of new learning,
growth, and connection through creativity. With so
much to explore and real world projects to create,
Skillshare empowers you to accomplish real
growth. It’s curated specifically for learning,
meaning there are no ads to distract you, and
they’re always launching new premium classes,
so that you can stay focused
on leveling up your skills.
And also if you’re one of the first 1,000
people to click the link in the description
can get a 1 month free trial of
Skillshare’s Premium Membership.
Just like a cell is made up of many organelles,
this channel is made up of many people who
want it to exist, and the people on the screen
right now are some of those people. They’re our
Patreon patrons and if you would like this show to
continue existing and also to get some cool perks,
one of them being knowing you are instrumental
to the existence of this channel, but
others being quite cool as well, you
can go to patreon.com/journeytomicro
If you want to see more from our
Master of Microscopes James Weiss,
you can check out Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, I bet you
can find a subscribe button somewhere nearby.